[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo ici au
parlement européen à bruxelles nous
sommes à 80 jours des élections
européennes et nous commençons dans
cette édition notre tour d'europe pour
situer les principaux enjeux dans
certains états membres pour notre
première escale cap à l'est dans le pays
de viktor orban
chantre de la démocratie libérale tenant
d'une ligne particulièrement dur sur
l'immigration et défenseurs d'une europe
chrétienne
notre reporter a tendu son micro aux
principales forces politiques en
présence en gris à quelques semaines de
ce scrutin décisif mais je vous propose
d'abord un tour d'horizon de l'actualité
européenne avec ce qu'ont pensé préparé
par aurélie d'afas
[Musique]
la france le propose au niveau européen
mais elle peine à l'obtenir
si la taxation des gares phare est une
proposition au niveau continental
elle va devenir une réalité en france
les géants du numérique devrait
désormais être taxés à hauteur de 3 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires
une trentaine de groupes internationaux
seraient concernés c'étaient les
élections législatives en estonie ce
week end le parti libéral la réforme
remporté le scrutin avec près de 29% des
voix devant le centre du premier
ministre sortant
en troisième position l'extrême droite
réalise une percée le parti
eurosceptique qui a notamment fait
campagne sur des thèmes nationalistes
réussit presque a triplé son score il
devrait désormais disposer de 31 sièges
au parlement
les élections c'est aussi ce qui
préoccupe emmanuel macron le président
français lance sa campagne pour les
européennes dans une interview à la
chaîne italienne rai uno
il a marqué la détente dans les
relations transalpine qualifiant de
simple péripétie les tensions
diplomatiques récentes en réaffirmant la
nécessité d'une europe unie où il donne
son cap pour les élections du 26 mai
nous avons besoin d'une europe plus
forte pour moi c'est le coeur de la
campagne qui s'ouvre cette campagne elle
ne doit pas être un choix entre une
ouverture béate et le retour au
nationalisme son opposition au
nationalisme
il l'a réaffirmé dans une lettre aux
européens adressé aux citoyens des 28
pays de l'union
dans leurs journaux nationaux et dans
leur langue dans ce texte aux allures de
programme il décline une série de
propositions remettre à plat l'espace
schengen créé une banque européenne du
climat pour financer la transition
énergétique ou encore instituer un
bouclier social garantissant par exemple
un salaire minimum européen
dans son adresse emmanuel macron la
firme
l'europe est en danger mais l'europe est
nécessaire et il se positionne en
défenseur de l'europe qui protège face
aux pièges nationaliste
[Musique]
et cette tribune d'emmanuel mâcon va
chercher à l'analyser en plateau ici
avec jean sébastien lefebvre bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le spécialiste des
questions européennes pour le site
d'information contexte alors cette
tribune publiée par le président
français il s'adresse directement aux
citoyens européens c'est finalement un
exercice assez inédit comment ça a été
perçu dans les différentes capitales
européennes alors en effet c'est un
exercice inédit dans le sens où c'est la
première fois qu'un président de la
république s'adresse directement aux
citoyens à l'ensemble des citoyens
ça a été plus ou moins bien perçue mais
en fonction des orientations politiques
on va dire des différents leaders ou
autre on a vu par exemple le premier
ministre espagnol qui est socialiste
plutôt centre centre gauche a félicité
le président français pour ces
propositions est trouvé ça très bien les
soutenir même chose pour le premier
ministre belge qui le premier a réagi en
disant je suis entièrement d'accord je
soutiens ces propositions mais c'est
normal finalement parce qu'ils sont de
la même famille politique c'est aussi un
centriste libéral qu'on va retrouver
dans la famille politique des libéraux
et démocrates au parlement européen
alors plus étonnant viktor orban le
premier ministre hongrois a salué cette
tribune alors le victor obinna
effectivement salué la tribune mais si
on lit en détail ce que dit le
porte-parole de viktor orban dans la
journée il a foi dit que de toute façon
emmanuel macron était un président pro
migration que ces mesures étaient à
rejeter et c'est parce que voilà il est
promis grand il veut déferlante
migratoire donc la rhétorique
traditionnelle de budapest là dessus et
même temps ils disent oui on salue parce
que comme ça ça permet le débat on va
pouvoir discuter et c'est donc c'est un
peu comment il salue mais en même temps
ils disent clairement que ils vont pas
accepter ce qui est forcément mis sur la
table parce que par exemple sur schengen
ça ne plaît pas l'anglais alors est-ce
que selon vous à emmanuel macron se
posant en leader de l'europe avec cette
tribune indirectement oui il ya toujours
cette idée chez emmanuel macron de mener
le combat pour réformer l'europe sur le
long terme amener à faire évoluer sur
les questions de protection commerciale
de de relations avec le reste du monde
et de souveraineté européenne comme il
dit mais en même temps s'adressant
directement aux citoyens il se pose
aussi en réformateur en était en
comment dire en intermède entre les
citoyens et les dirigeants celui
finalement siège au conseil européen
donc accès à au 27 autres chefs d'état
et de gouvernement mais là il dit voilà
moi je vous propose ça soit il cherche
du soutien en fait finalement au delà
des cercles habituels de pouvoir et est
ce que c'est le bon moment pour publier
cette tribune selon vous et pourquoi en
terme de timing oui on est un petit peu
dans le moment où la campagne va
commencer dans les opinions publiques
des différents pays on va commencer à
parler d'europe d'élections européennes
donc oui dans le timing c'est à peu près
c'est assez cohérent
surtout qu'on va avoir un sommet
européen dans trois semaines où les
élections européennes ont commencé à
peser on voit aussi parlé du break site
le bric cité dans trois semaines à peu
près donc oui on va dire que là dessus
il a bon ok cette tribune 1 c'est
finalement ici une sorte de programme
électoral qui ne dit pas son nom est
d'ailleurs le thème de l'immigration il
ya une place de choix
alors c'est un programme électoral mais
qui va au delà des élections européennes
dans le sens où ce qu'ils proposent en
grande partie ne relève pas de la
compétence des futurs députés européens
quand il dit on va créer un conseil de
sécurité de l'europe pour gérer les
questions extérieures etc
ça c'est pas le futur député en marche
qui va pouvoir le créer c'est une
décision des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement donc il ya des mesures
clairement oui les députés pourront
voter là dessus s exprimer mais il ya
d'autres choses plus grande sur la
vision la réforme de l'europe où ça
c'est du débat plus large
il va au delà du cadre des simples
élections après sur les questions
migratoires effectivement il en a parlé
alors on peut voir ça comme un petit
dire braqué à droite
ils essaient de de draguer en quelque
sorte l'électorat plutôt elle est rude
et y est c'est en france mais en même
temps si on regarde les lignes d'après
quand il dit je veux remettre à plat
schengen aussitôt il dit oui on va
protéger les frontières mais ça on va
dire c'est déjà le cas dans schengen et
les frontières doivent être fermées
contrôlé à l'extérieur c'est des
frontières intérieures qui ont été
enlevés mais il dit aussi solidarité et
là il ya un message à voir aussi envers
les pays de l'est où on a justement
viktor orban qui lui dit moi je veux
protéger mes frontières mais je veux pas
de solidarité sur la question de gestion
de droit d'asie
la migration et c'était aucun quota de
répartition à lévis grade refuse c'est
ça et donc du coup en en faisant le lien
entre solidarité et contrôle des
frontières on fait verser le en même
temps traditionnels d'emmanuel mâcon
c'est oui contrôle des frontières donc
il plaît plutôt à droite mais à la
solidarité à gauche alors le problème
c'est que c'est toujours plus facile de
faire la partie contrôle des frontières
que faire la partie solidarité qui
bloque clairement depuis plusieurs
années la réforme du droit d'asile
européen est complètement bloquée à
cause justement de l'opposition des pays
de l'est
cette remise à plat de l'espace schengen
est ce que ces nouveaux par rapport à
son grand discours sur l'europe à la
sorbonne en 2017
il en parlait pas de pad pas de cette
façon là mais il ya toujours la question
migratoire parce qu'elle revient c'est
un sujet d'actualité
dès qu'il ya plusieurs bateaux qui
arrivent yal'arrivée cette vie ni aussi
- d'extrême droite au pouvoir en italie
donc il est obligé d'en dire de
s'emparer du sujet ce que c'est un sujet
politique au sein de l'union européenne
c'est un sujet qui est discutée entre
chefs d'état et de gouvernement donc il
est obligé de s'y intéresser surtout il
est très critiqué en france sur le sujet
que la gauche qui dit vous n'avez pas
pris de bateaux quand les italiens
refusait d accueillir vous refuser de
prendre des migrants etc
donc c'est toujours voilà il faut qui
jongle comme il est au centre de
l'échiquier politique entre les deux
alors dans cette tribune emmanuel macron
parle de repli nationaliste mais on sent
qu'il ne s'étant pas trop sur cette
opposition entre nationalistes et
progressistes qu'il avait pourtant mis
en avant dans cette précédente prise de
parole pourquoi à votre avis je trouve
quand même qui le qui le dit en en
utilisant bric c'est à dire qu' il n'a
pas directement les confronter les
nationalistes comme il le faisait
souvent via viktor orban ou via les
polonais on sent que là dessus il
cherche quand même un petit peu
apaisement n'y a pas d'opposition
frontale
là mais ils fils de brick city dit au
début de la tribune il dit les gens les
hommes politiques vous ont menti ils
vous ont dit que ce serait génial de
sortir de l'union européenne que ce
serait facile et qui aurait que des
bénéfices et regarder voilà ces gens qui
vous ont tous promis mais finalement il
se passe rien et on doit pas faire la
même erreur et donc du coût de cette
manière il dit voilà moi je vais vous
dire la vérité c'est ça qu'il faut faire
et c'est là qu'il amène l'opposition
entre ceux qui veulent détruire l'europe
et ceux qui veulent la réformer mais en
même temps voilà il dit clairement on ne
peut pas garder le statu quo est là pour
le coup c'est un message plus vers une
partie une partie nord de l'europe
il ya de nombreux pays qui disent mais
finalement les choses vont très bien
pourquoi réformer la zone euro pourquoi
changer les règles et la main qu'on dit
non ça c'est un rapace sur le long terme
il faut qu'on tire des conséquences du
brics une tribune un qui marque en tout
cas à l'entrée en campagne d'emmanuel
macro merci beaucoup d'être venu
aujourd'hui nous éclairer sur cette
question comme promis nous prenons
maintenant la direction de budapest où
la campagne pour les européennes a déjà
commencé depuis trois semaines les murs
de la capitale sont recouverts
d'affichés particulièrement agressive
notamment à l'encontre du président de
la commission européenne
jean claude juncker ce sera peut-être la
provocation de trop pour viktor orban
qui pourrait voir sa formation le fidèle
expulsé du parti populaire européen en
attendant les sondages donnent son parti
largement gagnant face à une opposition
hongroise qui a beaucoup de mal à se
faire entendre
état des forces en présence à moins de
trois mois du scrutin avec ce reportage
signé flora sauvage
[Musique]
10 février 2019
viktor orban lance sa campagne pour les
élections européennes autour de son
thème de prédilection l'immigration
grand favori des sondages le premier
ministre au roi se pose en défenseur des
nations chrétiennes contre une vidéo
multi culturelle de l'europe
nous devons comprendre que les peuples
européens ont atteint un carrefour
historique que ceux qui décident en
faveur de l'immigration et des migrants
créée en réalité des nation métissée et
que les traditions historiques dans ces
pays sont menacés face à ce qu'il
considère comme une menace
le gouvernement hongrois a dévoilé mi
février une campagne d'affichage
agressive contre le milliardaire
d'origine hongroise george soros et le
président de la commission européenne
jean claude juncker vidéo à l'appui
victor ban les accuse d'un complot pour
submerger la hongrie deux migrants
est-ce facile mais n'affiche en
bourgogne il a qui plus est cette vision
est partagée dans la rue où les migrants
sont souvent vus comme la bête noire
c'est leur valeur leur mode de vie leur
religion qui me pose problème
moi j'ai vu à la télévision les migrants
qui arrivent et j'ai vu leurs chefs
religieux leur dire d'occuper l'europe
et d'investir notre territoire
ils ne leur ont pas dit de sainte hélène
ils nous sont totalement étrangers je ne
pense pas que bruxelles va nous forcer à
accueillir des hordes de migrants dont
on ne veut pas mais bon on a déjà assez
d'étrangers de toute façon dans ce pays
d'europe centrale de moins de 10
millions d'habitants où l' indice de
fécondité est l'un des plus bas d'europe
les sondages promettent aux fides le
parti de viktor orban une place de
favori que personne ne semble pouvoir
lui disputer comme l'expliquent ce
politologue
ils prospèrent sur un leitmotiv qui est
le suivant nous allons protéger la
hongrie des migrants et de bruxelles
c'est un message très populaire mais il
prospère aussi parce qu'il ya un
problème démocratique qui affecte
directement les élections car le fides a
des moyens financiers conséquents
d'ailleurs quand vous promener dans les
rues de budapest vous pouvez voir de
nombreuses affiches placardées par le
gouvernement avec des messages pro fides
tandis que les partis d'opposition sont
poursuivis pour de soi-disant problème
de détournement de fonds aux fins
l'opposition en hongrie a du mal à se
faire entendre
d'autant qu'un consortium géant
regroupant 476 titres pro
gouvernementaux a été créé à l'automne
2010 8
il y a un fort contrôle des médias par
le gouvernement il contrôle non
seulement la presse quotidienne
régionale mais aussi la télévision
publique
certains des médias en ligne bref une
quantité importante de la population ne
s'informe que par l'intermédiaire de ces
médias pro-gouvernementaux ainsi au sein
de la rédaction de maillard des mises
est le quotidien de référence
on prend fait et cause à l'image du
fides pour une hongrie forte
nous sommes dans l'union européenne
c'est vrai c'est un continent très varié
où on ne partage pas tous les mêmes
idées et parfois ici dans l'est de
l'europe uniquement parce qu'on n'est
pas très riche et qu'on a rejoint
l'union européenne plus tard on a
vraiment le sentiment qu'on nous traite
comme des européens inférieurs à ceux de
l'ouest dans les rues de budapest
la campagne pour se départager les 21
sièges de députés européens alloués à la
hongrie a déjà commencé deuxième force
d'opposition du pays
le jobbik compte actuellement trois
députés européens
difficile de distinguer ceux qui les
oppose aux fides la protection de notre
pays et de notre civilisation contre
l'immigration illégale de masse doit
être mise en place
et dans ce but nous sommes pour le
rétablissement des gardes à nos
frontières et d'une coopération étroite
avec frontex d'autres partis
d'opposition font figure d outsider
organes et ceux qui partagent ses idées
contribuer à affaiblir l'europe inspiré
dans marche môme ntoum tente de faire
entendre une autre voix avec des moyens
limités
là ce sont nos bénévoles qui sont en
train de coller les stickers ce sticker
dit que vous avez le droit de savoir que
viktor orban est le hongrois le plus
riche
beaucoup de gens n'osent pas voté contre
or ban car il pense que ça peut avoir
des conséquences dans leur vie ou sur
l'avenir de leurs familles et nous
voulons leur montrer qu'il y à une
alternative
c'est ce pourquoi nous nous battons
prouver que môme ntoum peut être une
alternative crédible à la politique de
viktor orban
l'enjeu est de taille
[Musique]
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau sylvie
guillaume bonjour bonjour vous êtes
membre des socialistes et démocrates et
vice-présidente du parlement européen
face à vous aujourd'hui pour discuter de
ce sujet rose à thoune bonjour vous êtes
polonaise membre du parti populaire
européen
alors on va reparler de ce reportage
dans quelques instants
mais je voudrais d'abord rappeler
quelques chiffres sur la hongrie c'est
un pays qui compte un peu moins de 10
millions d'habitants son économie
représente environ 1,3 pour cent du pib
européen la hongrie a rejoint lieu en
2004 et elle compte 21 députés au
parlement européen
elle est présidée par yann hausse hader
et son premier ministre on le sait c'est
viktor orban tous deux membres du fid
est un parti libéral à l'origine devenu
au fil du temps conservateur et
populiste à leur style vidyo mais on l'a
vu dans ce reportage cette campagne
d'affichage 1 particulièrement virulente
à l'encontre de jean-claude juncker le
président de la commission européenne
elle devrait être en place jusqu'à mi
mars et elle va laisser place à une
campagne qui cette fois visera france
timerman c'est le candidat de votre
parti pour les élections oui c'est de la
longue série de provocations de la part
de monsieur urban contre l'union
européenne ses représentants donc
j'espère que ces campagnes vont être
stoppés je crois que le parti populaire
européen essaye de faire stopper cette
campagne par conviction auprès de
monsieur urban ce que sam appelle aussi
comment remarque c'est que on a quand
même le sentiment que viktor orban prend
son opinion publique pour une imbécile
c'est à dire ne dit des phrases très
simple très caricatural sans expliquer
la réalité et je trouve que c'est faire
injure au peuple hongrois d'en rester à
des phrases qui sont aussi pour vos
quatre ici est très fort hills et très
caricatural ensuite tout à fait et
depuis longtemps malheureusement très
bien alors rose est soudain cette
campagne d'affichage on l'a dit on elle
pose la question de l'expulsion du
fidèle du parti populaire européen le
ppe devrait d'ailleurs se prononcer sur
cette question le 20 mars quelle est
votre position sur l'expulsion ou non du
fidèle
je suis désolé mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec marc
je suis désolé qu'il faut critiquer
totalement
un groupe est en partie les collègues
qui sont ensemble avec nos pneus et
surtout victor orban bien sûr et c'est
pas seulement à cause de cette histoire
avec l'affichage qui est complètement
incroyable et pendant encore une fois il
traverse la red line la ligne rouge
comme on dit mais leurs provocations
c'est pas seulement les provocations
mais c'est la destruction de la
démocratie dans son propre pays et son
propre pays et le pays membres de
l'union européenne
et c'est la destruction de deux niveaux
de la démocratie dans toute l'union
européenne nous sommes un organisme
finalement un donc tous cet organisme
nous devons vraiment protéger la
démocratie là là le respect pour le
droit
rule of law comme on dit ici et nous
allons avoir une main débat très sérieux
nous avons eu déjà plusieurs et la
décision va être prise le 20 mai suivait
bien écrit une lettre au président de
ppe monsieur dole avec les conditions
plusieurs conditions sur lesquelles on
pouvait rester mais je ne vois pas
vraiment de bonne volonté
deux côtés de monsieur obama alors
justement ce sont notamment les
allemands du ppe qui semble lâcher
victor hab
or ben ils étaient des soutiens
historiques du premier ministre hongrois
manfred weber on vous l'avait dit le
candidat de la droite européenne avait
félicité viktor orban pour sa réélection
en avril dernier
j'ai hâte de continuer à travailler avec
vous pour trouver des solutions communes
aux défis européens
mais le ton a changé dernièrement victor
ben suis le mauvais chemin politique
notamment en ce qui concerne le style ou
les questions fondamentales relatives à
l'ordre démocratique ce n'est pas la
voie du ppe manfred weber a depuis
déclaré qu'il se disait prêt à accorder
une dernière chance à viktor orban
sylvie guillaume quelle serait votre
réaction si viktor orban restait au sein
du ppe
je trouve qu'il y à beaucoup dormi
été beaucoup d'hypocrisie dans ce que
vous venez de rappeler de la part d'un
certain nombre de leaders du ppe pardon
madame tout mais quand j'entends que si
monsieur urban s'excuse c'est le retire
sa campagne s'il s'excuse donc auprès
des autres partis après tout on pourrait
passer l'épongé je trouve que c'est
plutôt du registre d'un surveillant de
collège qui surveille donc des élèves
qui font des bêtises et qui leur dit bon
allez on va passer l'épongé
si vous vous excusez c'est pas à la
hauteur madame thoune avez raison de
rappeler tout à l'heure que ce qui est
en cause avec viktor orban en hongrie
c'est l'état de droit c'est les attaques
contre les ong c'est les attaques contre
la justice contre les journalistes bref
sur la séparation des pouvoirs donc on
est dans une crise démocratique
extrêmement grave on peut pas gérer ça
juste en disant excusez-vous il ça passe
rapide et aussi à rodellar en politique
puisqu'il ya douze députés waouh je vais
y venir deuxième ambiguïté aussi chez
les français du ppe qui finalement
regarde ça avec beaucoup de distance et
ne prennent pas parti disent que
finalement tout cela pourrait se passer
parce qu'évidemment derrière vous avez
raison il ya une un problème majeur pour
je crois pour manfred weber qui envisage
d'être tranquille et le speed jeunes
candidates et envisage de dire des
dettes dans les top job de des
institutions européennes c'est le nombre
de membres du fidesz qui viennent
rejoindre ou qui deviendrait pu
rejoindre les rangs du ppe et avec les
recompositions politiques qui peuvent
intervenir avec d'autres groupes
d'autres personnalités ouvertement
eurosceptique pour ne pas dire europhobe
anti migrants dans le parlement européen
ceci pour constituer une force
alternative au ppe qui la met en grand
danger effectivement mais certains
membres du ppe ont voté pour le
déclenchement de l'article 7
oui et moi tout seul il ya eu là aussi
une très grande diversité des votes
je sais ce qu'a fait madame tools et
c'est ce qu'on fait un certain nombre de
français j'essaie ce qu'on fait un
certain nombre d'allemands mais tout le
monde n'était pas sur la même position
et donc les mêmes et compris des motions
du pays a refusé d' enclencher de
demandes et l'enclenchement de l'article
donc il faut avoir les idées claires sur
ce sujet il faut que le ppe soient plus
francs du collier d'une certaine manière
vis-à-vis de ce voisin de 700
participants très turbulent est très
dangereux je crois pour la démocratie en
europe
rose est une pour vous c'est probable
que victor valdes soient expulsés du ppe
le 20 mars
je crois que c'est très probable
malheureusement c'est très probable pour
pour défendre le ppe il faut dire que
nous avons pris les pas pour un peu
contrôlées au calme elle fides dans ses
ambitions de détruire la démocratie
l'article 7 comme vous avez dit été
déclenché et le ppe a voté pour pour cet
article 7
moi j'ai vu la grande majorité a voté
pour déclencher l'article 7 mai
mais ce n'est pas une décision facile je
dois avouer parce que renvoyer quelqu'un
aussi bien ont travaillé comme dans un
groupe des partis des des pays membres
c'est la solution la plus facile mais
quelle solution est telle qu'ils nous
sert le mieux est ce que ça va changer
organes et son parti pour mieux si on
leur envoie du groupe ppe quand il ne va
renforcer les groupes de extrême droite
le hic c'est que ces douze députés
partent dans les rangs de l'extrême
droite deux députés vont partir je
crains dans les groupes d'extrême droite
les renforcer orban ne va pas avoir plus
aucun frein parce que là le ppe était un
peu un frein trop doux où il n'a pas
respecté j'avoue donc finalement on va
se séparer le plus probablement il va
pas il va devoir quitter le ppe mais ça
me va pas améliorer malheureusement la
situation ni pour les hongrois
ni au parlement européen mais d'autres
côté nous le ppe
comme les autres groupes démocratiques
nous devons tenir une ligne on ne peut
pas montrer aux citoyens européens
comptent tolère ce genre de comportement
qui est extrêmement grave
je suis polonaise donc je sais de quoi
je parle
la pologne qui est aussi
sous le coup d'une procédure de
l'article 7 ans et une procédure qui
peut mener l'état membres incriminés à
être privé de son droit de vote au
conseil et je voudrais d'ailleurs
maintenant à que l'on s'arrête un
instant sur le fameux groupe de vice
grave car il est difficile de parler de
la hongrie dans l'europe sont l'évoqué
ce groupe compte quatre états membres de
l'union européenne la hongrie justement
mais aussi la pologne la république
tchèque et la slovaquie quatre pays
d'europe centrale qui avait choisi de se
réunir en 1991 à la fin de la guerre
froide pour faciliter leur intégration
au sein de l'union européenne et de
l'otan depuis quelques années ce groupe
gagne en notoriété car il est utilisé
par ses membres pour défendre des
positions communes au sein de l'union
européenne notamment une politique
restrictive en matière d'immigration
finalement quand on parle de dérive
démocratique en gris rose à tout vous
avez aussi l'impression que la pologne
est sur un chemin parallèle à la hongrie
la pologne je ne dirais pas le
gouvernement je dirais oui
le parti pis il faut vraiment avoir une
grande différence entre ceux qui dit la
majorité de papy polonais et ceux qui
prônent ans le parti qui est en
gouvernant maintenant parce que le 84 je
crois pour cent de la part des polonais
disent oui à l'europe 18 au respect au
droit mais c'est comme ça que la
démocratie fonctionne les élections ont
montré aux ont donné la majorité on a
voté pour le parti droit et justice qui
est maintenant en un gouvernement qui
gouverne maintenant et c'est un parti
qui est qui veut avoir une autre europe
une europe des pays membres qui sont
complètement indépendants l'un de
l'autre et il appelle sa souveraineté et
c'est vrai que nous souffrons en ce
moment et je crains que toute l'europe
souffre
sobrement et cette procédure de
l'article 7 allée efficace selon vous
parce que elle est un peu vouée à
l'échec puisque il faut un vote à
l'unanimité des états membres
je comprends très bien que les autres
pays qui respecte les autres
gouvernement qui respecte l'état de
droit ne veulent pas que au conseil les
politiciens qui ne respect pas notre
droit commun en le droit de vote
alors ce groupe devise gras dans six
vidéos mon avis c'est un groupe de
résistance
aujourd'hui à bruxelles ils bloquent
notamment certaines questions notamment
ce dossier migratoire on a vu que cette
réforme de l'asile et bien été
impossible à mettre en place
oui en même temps les pays du groupe de
visegrad ne sont pas les seuls à bloquer
la réforme fiscale harmonisation du
droit d'asile en europe il ya des pays
qui n'en font pas parti qui bloque aussi
sur un certain nombre de sujets mais je
crois que c'est une question
effectivement d'image aussi donné il
faut faire la distinction effectivement
sur les sanctions qu'on a envie
d'imposer à dirigeants parce qu'il a une
attitude particulièrement délétère et
l'impact que ça effectivement sur la
population et c'est très important est
le message que moi j'aurais envie de
délivrer au peuple hongrois ou aux
tchèques et aux slovaques qui ont
polonais c'est qu'il faut continuer de
croire en la démocratie
il faut continuer de se renseigner sur
ce que fait l'union européenne pour bien
les importantes dans les actions qui
sont menées auprès d'eux combien il faut
arrêter de croire sur parole un certain
nombre de faits qui sont délivrés dans
le pignon monsieur ban dit il faut
freiner il faut ce qu'il faut fermer
complètement la migration en même temps
il a accueilli plus de 300 vénézuélien
sur son territoire il augmente les
bourses pour les étudiants étrangers est
manifestement sa population décroît il
ya un problème démographique énorme
engrais donc il faut que l'on continue
nous de notre côté européen a argumenté
auprès de ses opinions publiques là pour
dénoncer effectivement les agissements
des dirigeants et faire croire aux
valeurs et aux priorités de l'europe
la hongrie un qui fera sans doute encore
beaucoup parler d'elle pendant
cette campagne pour les européennes
merci à toutes les deux d'avoir été nos
invités aujourd'hui merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis c'est ainsi que se termine
notre émission aujourd'hui mais vous
pouvez la retrouver en replay sur nos
différents sites et cpam public sénat et
rtbf.be très belle semaine à tous et à
très bientôt
[Musique]